directions ladies and gentlemen
today is an important day in the
Netherlands
today we remember those who lost their
lives in the Second World War
and in wars and peace operations since
then
it is a privilege
and an honor to welcome an extraordinary
guest today
President zielinski we are truly honored
to have you here today welcome in The
Hague
thank you
Mr President welcome into Hague welcome
in the city of peace and justice
ladies and gentlemen the war in our
country and its almost eight decades ago
and yet the memory is still resonate
almost every family still tells stories
of the war
stories of loss of fear of hunger
but also stories of bravery and
resistance
of Heroes who have fought for freedom
and peace
and 78 years later this war is still
part of Who We Are
so every year on this day
we remember
every year we think back of those who we
lost
and tomorrow Liberation day we remember
that freedom must never be taken for
granted
people have fallen and died for it and
they fight and die for it still
and in Ukraine as we all know this
freedom is a more severe threat
every day
every day Russian missile stanks drones
and soldiers
objective
and every day Brave ukrainians step to
protected
and protect what is theirs and president
zielinski every day since the illegal
Russian invasion you and your people
have shown us what it means to fight for
freedom
and we deeply admire you for doing that
and please know that Anonymous will
continue to stand with you
we have supported you and we will
continue to support you first of all
with weapons because the harsh reality
is that there is no substitute for
Success on the battlefield
but also with humanitarian aids with
harboring refugees
and with help in rebuilding your
wonderful country
just as others have helped us
rebuild ours
ladies and gentlemen
illegal Wars cannot go unpunished
there cannot be peace without Justice
it is the only answer it is the only
answer to aggression and war crimes
it is the only answer that will ensure a
loss in peace
and that is a lesson we have learned
from the war all those years ago
and it is a lesson we must continue to
apply today
Ukrainian prosecutors have registered 85
000 Russian war crimes since the
beginning of the war
that is hundreds of crimes every single
day
man women
children are being cowardly raped
tortured
and murdered
schools hospitals and houses are being
born
children are being kidnapped
every single day
and these ordinary innocent people who
have done nothing
to deserve this terrible faith
and we can never accept this
and we will do everything in our power
to ensure that Russia is being held to
account
but we can only do this together
with the International Community
together with all those
want peace and Believe In Justice
and that is why we in the Netherlands
strongly support accountability
initiatives
it is why we send forensic teams to
Ukraine and is why we are ready and
willing to host prosecution centers
damages registers and courts here in The
Hague
these are important steps
but there are only first steps
the roads to accountability is low and
full of setbacks
it requires perseverance and a special
sense and a special kind of resolutions
the kind I see every time I speak with
you Mr President and the kind of see in
ukrainians every single time I've had
the opportunity to visit the country
Mr President we're in this together we
will continue to support you continue to
support you in your fight for Freedom
sovereignty and adjust peace until you
celebrate your own Liberation day Mr
President
thank you
thank you very much
first of all
uh first of all I would like to thank
you for your attention and your respect
for Ukraine and I have felt I have felt
today thank you very much this is
uh attention and respect from people who
value freedom
and do not tolerate tyranny as much as
we do not in Ukraine thank you very much
dear Minister hooks from a dear members
of parliament dear ambassadors and
journalists dear representatives of
international organizations political
and judicial communities dear people
first of all people people
of the Netherlands and I'm glad to be in
your strong country now
now the land of freedom and Justice
which are Universal values and it is
about these things
that I will speak today of course of
course we all want to see different
Vladimir
here
in The Hague
the one who deserves to be
sentenced for these criminal actions
right here in the capital of the
international law
and I'm sure we will see that happen
when we win
and we will win
and man we will not just on the
battlefield not just against this
aggression look at how countries around
the world are coming together to help
ukrainians
defend themselves
what is at the heart of this desire to
help
the feeling that more than the faith of
one country is at stake the feeling that
more can be achieved than the defeat of
one aggressor
we can now stop Wars of aggression as
such we can defeat aggression as a
criminal idea that
originates in the mindset of someone who
is used to impunity
immunity is the key that opens the door
to aggression
if you look at any War any any war of
aggression in the history and they all
have one thing in common
the perpetrators of the world didn't
believe they would have to stand to
answer for what they did
they must tend to answer for war
however brings war must receive judgment
in impunity aggressors means destroying
their origins of aggression victory in
the world is won by Force of Arms
that's how how their job gets done
to maintain our defense and gradually
prepare our active actions
but we know that the last thing peers
after Victory is achieved by nothing
else but the sense of values towards the
wall is the strength of freedom and of
law
which fast forward to the full of Ensure
Justice
not hybrid promises
instead of Human Rights
real freedom
not hybrid impunity and symbolic
formalities but full sale Justice not
hybrid peace and consumption Pleasures
or violence on the front line but
reliable peace when one respects values
true Freedom True Justice through peace
is suspected instead of hybrid forms but
it's exactly what we need now
and now
um December is 6 000 and 139
this is the number
converted number of war crimes
occupies this April alone
these Russian crimes led to the death of
207 Ukrainian civilians among them are
11 children another 17 children are four
and four hundreds of us were injured in
a month alone
Invasion has been going on for the 15th
month
just yesterday
49 we are wounded
students
and it also has more than nine years ago
with a occupation of
the occupational foreign
[Music]
in the Little Bus
filtration camp that Russia set up on
our independent land
every prisoner who was tortured in the
Russian captivity and at every city
deliberately burned by Russia and all
the being Somebody by the Dutch people
after the dawning of
mh17
flied with the use of the Russian
weapons by the Russian house exactly by
the Russian hands and
um
in a memory of all those whose last were
taken by Russian
please
thank you
thank you very much
France
um
Russian crime led to all of these
stripes
this is a crime of aggression the sound
of evil
the primary crime
there should be a responsibility for
this crime and it can only be enforced
by the Tribunal
Europe and the world have already had to
deal with something like this as a
result we can see the following words in
the text of the Judgment of the
international tribunal in Nuremberg
to war
a war of progression is not only an
international crime it is the Supreme in
international crime differing only from
other other war crimes in that it
contains within itself the
accumulated evil of the whole
that's absolutely true we must inform
the experience of the environmental
process into operating rule
that's why we insist on the tribunal
creation
we understand tradition of inevitable
punishment of Oppression then there will
be a tradition of guaranteed
non-repetition of aggression
if we want True Justice we should not
look for excuses
[Music]
international law
but make make bold decisions that we
that will correct the short kinds of
those rules that unfortunately exist in
international law
this is exactly what the creator of
Nuremberg did we should do the same now
it will be a witness for you and for us
and for all of the Nations to live
through just only to the history
it will be until our children and our
grandchildren to hand the problem that
we can solve that's what the tribunal is
for
that
that sustainability of peace
resist from the complete us towards the
aggressive ladies and gentlemen
it is wrong that someone in the world is
still afraid to give full force to
Justice
you and I are not afraid and I am sure
most of the World is Not Afraid
the aggressor must feel the full power
of Justice only him yet this is our
historical responsibility of the modern
generation to make the total passion for
regression inevitable to prevent the
immersion against our country and also
new words there are the potential
aggressors in the world and in the world
must see Justice to see peace fully
fully secured
Ukraine of course will
ensure responsibility for most for most
of the crimes of the Russian occupieslam
and we're thankful to the international
criminal court and to their entire team
working at and with the ICC for the sake
of justice but only one institution is
capable of responding
to the original crime the crime of
aggression
Al
tribunal not something hybrid
that can formally close to the topic not
some compromise
[Music]
politicians who say that the case is
allegedly done
but it's true
into the room true
full-fledged tribunal true and full
Justice
prime minister the government the
department for being with us on this
path foreign
[Music]
I thank you for the fact that for you
and us Justice really matters
thank you
the Netherlands let's let Justice really
work and I learned today as always as
always on the force of mind at eight
o'clock in the evening
on our honor the memory of all those who
who's lost
also
remember ukrainians men and women and us
and children
who would have been alive now but
for this immigration the war we didn't
want
the one we have to make the last and
we'll do it
thank you